if you can't take the heat get out of
the molotov that's right it's time to
talk about 1G and you've probably seen
this in twitch chat when someone kills
themselves with a molotov in Counter
Strike but where did it come from back
off thankfully for automatic cu the
molotov gets scadoodle it locked him
into the tree couldn't extinguish it
couldn't get away it was going to get
Stewie with the
sa Summit buddy how you doing Stewie
says hello Jared Lazar also known as
Summit 1G is one of csgo's most popular
streamers but he's had stints on a
number of teams in the past one of those
was as a standin for sp's Professor
Chaos at dream Haack Austin 2016 Summit
found himself in the spotlight after
clutching out a round against counter
logic Gaming's fugly winning the game in
the process only he didn't win the round
because this happened trades it back and
now it's Summit in the 1 V one to try
and close this out against fugle fugle
playing it aggressively now but su's
going to clutch it and splice look close
out map number one
16-1 oh
wait
[Applause]
what okay then no what
happened oh no
Summit
no but no big deal right just take a
round and win the match oh my goodness
wrong
not only did splice drop that map 16 to
19 in overtime they also lost D two 10
to6 goodby Summit and goodbye splice as
they're the first team eliminated that
meant they ultimately bombed out of
group a with an 0 and2 record not
exactly a great way to be remembered at
a tournament like when it happened I was
like dude my life's over like I can't
even step
foot in the world right now ever since
the embarrassing fail whenever someone
loses a 1 V Z to a Molotov it's referred
to as a summit or 1G for
sure come
on all
[Music]
right just move on just move past it all
right move past it we wanted to get our
name for ourselves in Counter Strike and
it's kind of sad that we got it like
this but like I always like wanted to
spot for myself like oh that's Summit
box right there Summit box now when you
to a Molotov by yourself it's called p a
summit Henny goes down and finess
getting wool banged then putting himself
on fire no Summit I hope you're watching
the game brother because this is uh it's
going to be a bit of almost a shout out
summit now finding humor in the incident
opened up on what it was like to be on
the receiving end of such an Infamous
blunder I've never like had a harder
time to continue playing than after that
moment it was it was rough man it was
rough
terrorists
win and then after we lost that map I
was I was done man so there you have it
the next time your team's offer walks
into their own motov while their shins
melt you'll know exactly what to put in
chat yo bro they have free donuts in the
kitchen Donuts smoking just look out for
that blazing Inferno in the
hallway what counterterrorist win Molly
makes you do strange
[Music]
things thanks for watching if you want
more great content be sure to hit that
subscribe
button